mr. Churchill scene 2 take 1 ladies and
gentlemen permit me to claim your
attention if you're around Hillsdale
very long you'll find out that whence in
Churchill is important why Churchill did
things that no one's ever done he was in
the center the two greatest wars in
history Churchill was smart lightning
quick he was funny also he was eloquent
and eloquent integrator perfusion and
think anybody you know we remember
things she said there's a completion of
our tasks both at home and abroad
advanced Britannia long live the cause
of freedom god save the king he won the
Nobel Prize for Literature he wrote
about 50 books he worked very hard very
long hours sometimes he'd have people
with him until 2:00 in the morning and
he organized his life to produce 15 or
20 hours of work a day
and then he was involved in everything
so his archive is huge the story's life
is huge and you know he became at the
end of his life the greatest man in the
world so that means that everything in
his life becomes the subject of study
and Churchill understood all and
Churchill I had this very bright Sun and
Churchill said wrote to him and said I
want you to write my biography so in
1961 and two Randolph Churchill launches
this thing
he hired a research assistant named
Martin Gilbert and Randolph Churchill
died in 1968 and Martin Gilbert a young
historian who'd been working on the
biography and had published three books
already at a young age got picked in
1977 I was a Rotary fellow I had a
scholarship to go to England I was gonna
write my doctoral thesis on Churchill
and then one of my teachers knew Martin
Gilbert asked him to meet me and so we
had a talk and well he offered me a job
August 1977 two weeks later he hired
woman who's now my wife of almost 40
years
[Music]
and then in 2001 darn if you didn't up
and asked me for a job here at Hillsdale
College and I gave to her
anyway I said I need to buy your papers
because we made a deal about 20 years
ago that if you didn't finish the
document volumes to the biography we
made a deal that if you didn't finish it
I would because Church will set this up
we shall fight on the beaches fight on
the landing grounds we shall fight in
the fields and in the streets we shall
fight in the Hills we shall never
surrender the college has the Churchill
project now which have just been
finished in now number 23 so 8 plus 23
there are 31 volumes in the official
biography of Winston Churchill we want
people to understand Churchill first of
all because it's just beautiful to see
some of the things he did and understand
what produced some it tells you
something about the nature of human life
as Churchill would say both its triumph
and its tragedy but then second we want
people who are interested in governance
being leading citizens including
politicians we want them to learn from
this guy who has so much to teach
here's something that's done that's
worthy that's gonna have an abiding
influence and it's not going to make
anybody rich and if you want to honor
and freedom and the things who fight for
people who fight for it and secure it
and the truth what better way to do it
intend to tell the story of Churchill
and make it available in new ways and
keep the idea of Churchill alive because
Churchill is an example of the kind of
thing that is essential to human nature
and helps to solve some of the essential
problems it faces in the moments when
things mattered a lot people often look
to Churchill including in the moment
where they mattered the most
[Music]